so the way that I like to describe my
work is that it's it's developing
statistical methods to do something
without having to do everything so let
me elaborate a little bit on that I'm
particularly interested in is linkages
between the overall macro economy and
financial markets and so one could
imagine that to do this with a model
you've got to have a detailed model the
macro economy you've got to have a
detailed inside that a detailed model of
the how financial markets work inside
that economy in order to kind of get off
the ground and it's very handy is to
instead just be able to do pieces of
that without having to do the whole
thing simultaneously and so the methods
that that I developed were aimed at
being able to understand that piece
without having to have a full-blown
model of both financial markets and the
entire economy eventually one has to put
all the pieces together but but it's
nice to be able to kind of look at a
portion of it and then when we come back
and add much more detail along these
various different dimensions